so population growth is a very real
concern when we were hunter-gatherers or
at five million people on the planet now
there's seven billion and we're headed
towards nine billion maybe even 10
billion by the middle of the century and
some environmental would say population
growth is at the root of all
environmental problems and many people
would say hey we have to end at wait and
shrink the population dramatically well
first population growth is slowing in
1950 the average woman on earth had five
children over the course of her lifetime
now the average woman on earth will have
about two and a half children over the
course of her lifetime and when that
which is too that's the magic
replacement rate and we're on track to
hit that so we're by the middle of the
century we will have ended population
growth most likely now all that having
been said is a smaller population better
because human brains are the sources of
ideas and ideas multiply all the
resources and make your life better so
ask yourself this would you be better
off if fewer people had lived before you
or if more people had lived before you
if you were maybe it would have used up
fewer finite resources but then fewer
people would have come up with all these
great ideas that enhance your life
whether it's antibiotics or the electric
light or the internet or television or
radio or the automobile all of those
came from human minds so human minds are
a ultimate source of wealth in a certain
sense in the same way that human mouths
are consumption is a is a depleted of
some resources so we have to find a
balance now the other very exciting
thing is that it's possible that more
people means more innovation even more
than it means more consumption what I
mean is twice as many people means twice
as much consumption but it might mean
three times as much innovation and we
can see that throughout history if you
look at the starting points of different
disconnected continents the ones that
started with the highest population the
highest land area were the ones where
the most innovation happened you look at
Eurasia and Africa together as one large
landmass
that's where the bulk of the innovations
over the last several millennium came
from up until the time of Columbus when
people connected again and that's in
large part because they started with a
larger population the Americas had a
Stone Age technology agriculture
somewhat but didn't have the metals or
the printing press or the astronomy that
it existed there in Europe and Asia
Australia smaller and more separate
didn't even have agriculture but they
did have some tools the boomerang and
and other sophisticated tools they
created Tasmania separate Australia and
smaller didn't even have those tools so
the places that had the most people
produce the most new ideas those ideas
then spread everyone in those land
masses so it's a double-edged sword
people are sources not just consumption
but of innovation